[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
australia aprobó la primera ley en el
mundo que obliga a las gigantes
tecnológicas a pagar a las empresas
periodísticas por el contenido que éstas
generan y que se mueven en sus
plataformas una medida que podría
establecer un precedente mientras varios
países anuncian la intención de
adaptarla en sus territorios cómo
funciona esta ley porque los editores de
noticias exigen esta remuneración
empezamos
el parlamento australiano finalmente
aprobó la ley del gobierno que busca que
las grandes tecnológicas como facebook y
google remuneren a las empresas de
medios de comunicación por los
contenidos que éstas generan y que se
mueven en las plataformas digitales de
esta manera ambas partes deberán
negociar las tarifas y en caso de que
las conversaciones fracasen habrá un
árbitro del gobierno que determinará los
precios que las tecnológicas deberán
pagar a los medios nacionales la medida
se revisará un año después de que entre
en vigencia pero aún no hay claridad
cuándo será la ley fue aprobada luego de
una serie de enmiendas que surgieron
tras el diálogo entre el gobierno y
facebook luego de que la red social
bloqueara las noticias dentro de
australia y evitará que fuera del país
los usuarios pudieran ver o compartir
noticias de medios australianos google
por su parte había amenazado con
bloquear su motor de búsqueda en el país
pero que llevó al gobierno australiano a
sacar adelante esta ley el proyecto
partió a raíz de una investigación en
2018 de la comisión australiana de
competencia que reveló que hay un
desequilibrio en los ingresos
publicitarios entre los medios de
comunicación principalmente impresos y
las tecnológicas en pocas palabras que
compañías como facebook se estaban
llevando a la mayor parte de la
publicidad el organismo encontró que en
2018 de cada 100 dólares australianos
gastados por anunciantes 49 fueron a
google y 24 a facebook por ello reitero
que esto amenaza la viabilidad de los
modelos comerciales de los medios y su
capacidad para monetizar el periodismo
lo que ha llevado al recorte en el
número de periodistas en las salas de
redacción durante la última década las
tecnológicas se defienden y alegan que
son los medios los que se benefician de
sus plataformas ya que gracias a ellas
llevan las noticias a un público más
amplio
generando les millones de clics
son los propios editores quienes eligen
compartir sus historias en las redes
sociales o ponerlas a disposición de
otros para que las compartan porque
obtienen valor al hacerlo por eso tienen
botones de sus sitios que animan a los
lectores a compartirlos si se hace clic
en un enlace que se comparte en facebook
se les dirigirá fuera de la plataforma
del sitio web del editor de esta manera
el año pasado facebook generó
aproximadamente 5 mil 100 millones de
referencias gratuitas a editores
australianos por un valor estimado de
407 millones de dólares australianos
para la industria de las noticias
las afirmaciones repetidas ampliamente
en los últimos días de que facebook roba
o toma el periodismo original para su
propio beneficio siempre fueron y siguen
siendo falsas la razón por la que la ley
solo menciona a google y facebook
obedece a que son estas empresas las que
tienen el poder en el mercado de la
publicidad y la búsqueda de referencias
de noticias ambas compañías ya han
anunciado millonarios acuerdos para
respaldar a la industria de las noticias
pero preocupa que se excluya a los
medios pequeños que tan afectados podría
verse el modelo de negocio de estas
compañías ana ojeda abogada especialista
en nuevas tecnologías nos explica
consecuencia económica que va a traer
para google y para facebook que es que
van a tener que sentarse a negociar con
los medios de comunicación seguramente
los grandes y los medianos dudo que
google facebook quiera sentarse con los
pequeños
medios de comunicación a negociar y pues
además de esto va a traer una
repercusión bastante importante porque
van a tener que desembolsillar un buen
porcentaje de sus ganancias para pagar a
los medios de comunicación lo cual yo
creo que es bastante interesante porque
va a democratizar un poco el juego que
evidentemente está haciendo dominados de
hace años por las grandes 20 el mundo
siguió de cerca el proceso de la
legislación la cual podría haberse
replicado a nivel global de hecho ya
varios países se encaminan a ello se
espera que durante los próximos meses el
gobierno canadiense redacte una
legislación similar a la de australia
aunque otra opción es seguir el ejemplo
de francia donde una regulación obliga a
google a negociar con los editores de
noticias y remunerarlos por la
reproducción de sus contenidos por
ejemplo fragmentos de noticias que
aparecen en las búsquedas se trata de
una ley de derechos de autor de la unión
europea para junio todos los países del
bloque deberán adoptar versiones
nacionales
esta directiva algunos eurodiputados
consideran que esta medida no es
suficiente y proponen copiar la ley
australiana sin embargo esta normativa
es defendida por la vicepresidenta de la
comisión europea
con respecto a lo que está pasando en
australia ahora mismo es en gran parte
una cuestión de copyright la legislación
sobre el copyright donde como editor
tienes derecho a recibir un pago por tu
contenido sólo se ha transpuesto de en
francia y actualmente están avanzando
con acuerdos entre editores y algunas de
las plataformas yo no hago un juicio
sobre si eso es perfecto o no solo digo
que en materia de copyright la
eurocámara y el consejo han dado pasos
muy importantes y se implementarán en
todos los estados miembros este ver
estamos bajo los grandes medios de
comunicación de australia resultarán
beneficiados y aunque algunos celebraron
la aprobación de esta ley y los acuerdos
alcanzados con facebook otros se
mostraron escépticos el programa de
televisión today de la cadena nine
network se mostró optimista de poder
volver a publicar contenidos en su
página de facebook con un titular que
dice la pelea de facebook se termina por
otro lado el vice news titula el código
de negociación de los medios ha sido
aprobado por el parlamento pero todavía
no descartamos otra prohibición de
noticias por parte de facebook es bien
news publicó un trino en el que dice
regresa
pero no confíen en facebook para obtener
sus noticias y además publicó una lista
de otras plataformas y aplicaciones en
las que los usuarios pueden ver sus
contenidos
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra emisión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www punto
frente a 24 punto com
[Música]